Welcome to "Ear Biscuits",
the podcast, where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a
long time, I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're hearing about your
near-death experiences.
Yes.
We're taking advantage of this line,
we got this phone call line.
This phone call line.
A hotline,
Man, I love it.
I love people's voices.
1-888.
EARPOD1.
I love people's voices.
All you gotta do is call in
when we put a prompt
on the Twitter machine.
Yeah.
So, and these are literally-
We have a Twitter machine.
Near-death experiences.
And what I mean by that
is like people almost died
and nearly died.
We asked for ones that were
funny or bizarre specifically.
And we got, and maybe
there's a serious one
or two in there too.
I am embarking on a journey.
I'm making an investment.
I'm learning something new.
I am currently being
trained to do something
to be certified.
TaeKwonDo?
And nope.
And it could lead to a
near-death experience.
It could lead to a death experience.
Parachuting?
But it could also lead
to like an eyeopening,
heart-opening, life-changing.
Heart-opening?
Yeah.
Future-defining experience,
relationship defining experience for me
and a significant other in my life.
You're really building this up.
Yeah.
So, I think this is the right episode
to let you know.
You gonna start playing
Magic, The Gathering?
No, I'm open to it, but that's not it.
I am learning to scuba dive.
Ah.
I am becoming scuba certified.
I knew that, I was just playing dumb.
Yeah.
Ever since, and I just wanna tell you,
I've been waiting to tell you
about the process of training.
Get you wet?
Back when we went on tour,
we were in Australia and we
were like, "You know what,
when you're coming back from Australia,
there's that place called Fiji."
Yeah.
Might as well fly over it.
And we went scuba diving that one day.
No, snorkeling.
No, we didn't.
We went snorkeling.
When none of us are certified.
And I had just a magical
experience under the water,
like swimming in the
reef in the tidal zone
on this island that this boat took us to.
And it was just like, so meditative.
I thought I was, and I
think I talked about it
on the podcast.
Yeah.
As a highlight of that vacation years ago
that I was gonna cry in my mask.
You can't do that 'cause you'll die.
No, it was just so awesome.
And then that's when I
started to think, "Man,
I'd really like to scuba dive."
And then I start talking to Chase,
you know Chase is scuba certified?
Well, okay.
So I'm having some conversations with him.
Let me interject.
Because when you started
talking about scuba diving,
you talked about it in
a way that there was a,
there seemed to be a heavy
dose of fear involved.
And every time you brought it up,
it was like you were
stepping across a precipice
into like a gauntlet of
sorts, so explain that.
Because I have a fear of being underwater.
That's the problem.
And specifically, holding my breath.
I mean, I jump in my
pool and I go underwater,
hold my breath.
I'm swimming around.
I'm like very much aware
that there's this timer
going off in my body.
That's like if you don't get to the place
where you can breathe air
soon you're gonna die.
It's an immediate feeling for me.
Well, it's an important
survival mechanism.
But, you know, and I
always chalked it up to,
I was never a pool boy.
I was never, you were a pool boy,
you went to the Keith Hills pool.
Growing up, did a lot of swimming.
I did very little swimming
in a pool environment
where you like, hold your breath
and you get comfortable
holding your breath.
You were mostly a bathtub swimmer.
Yeah.
Or like a river swimmer.
And you don't spend a lot of time on,
you're more of wading and treading water.
No ocean swimming?
Not a lot.
I mean, ocean, it's more like body surfing
and stuff like that,
you're on the surface.
I didn't do a bunch of like...
Oh, the diving in the ocean.
That's the fun part.
Like when I would go to
frigging the Keith Hills pool
for the pool parties,
they would do that thing
where everybody would-
Cross the pool.
Cross the pool and be one guy
in there trying to tag you
and you and a bunch of other
people could just dive in,
swim to the very bottom
of the pool and come up
on the other side and never get tagged.
And here I am like flailing around on top.
I can swim.
But something about being underwater.
You're not a submarine, man.
My mom is afraid of
swimming, as a kid she dove
into a pool and hit her head,
and then she never swam again.
Well maybe her DNA was
altered when that happened.
And it got passed to you somehow,
that can happen, you know,
DNA can be altered by events.
Maybe that's what it is.
I didn't experience any trauma,
but the Fiji snorkeling
experience was so formative for me
that I was like, I wanna do this.
I wanna be able to go under that water
and not have to come up.
It's a great idea.
And plus I think I'm gonna
have to overcome this fear.
And then I tried to talk Christy into it.
She wasn't going for it,
but Lincoln was up for it.
I was like, Lincoln, "We're going,
we're planning this big trip to Hawaii."
I was like, "Dude, we're
gonna scuba dive in Hawaii."
And he was like, "All right.
Yeah, I'll do it with you."
This is also maybe the
plot of White Lotus.
Did that enter into your...
Yeah.
The teenage-
The father, son.
Yeah, they actually did that too.
He's like, "Let's get
scuba certified, man."
Well, I'd made up my mind before then-
But that put you over the top.
I didn't put any plans in place.
And then when I watched
White Lotus, I was like,
"I'm gonna put these plans in place.
See how this teenager's life was changed.
Like he found his calling in the ocean."
Spoiler.
Oh, well it's a nice storyline,
but I wouldn't call it a spoiler.
I mean, you're the one
who's sensitive to spoilers.
I'm just joking.
And so I said, "All
right, I'm gonna do this."
Started talking to
Chase about the process.
He made a recommendation
to Hollywood Divers,
shout out to Hal and the
team that I linked up with.
You gotta take an online course.
Because Lincoln and I
were doing it together
it took a number of months
for us to get through it.
You watch a video, you read some stuff,
you answer some questions.
If you don't get it right.
You gotta answer all the questions again.
But there's like five questions at a time.
And it, I mean, it was
probably cumulatively
over three hours' worth of stuff.
And then at the end, there's
like a 70-question test.
I'm like, "Lincoln you're, dude,
you're used to taking tests.
You show up and go to
school any day of a week.
You're you like, 'All
right, another test.'
Last test I took was a
freaking driving test.
When I moved to California,
before that when's the last test I took?"
like, test-taking is a skill.
So I was like, "Man,
I'm gonna be out just because a freaking,
I don't even know how to take tests.
Like, I don't know how
to retain information."
Did he beat you on the test?
I let him take the 70-question test
a little bit ahead of me.
And he's moving fast.
I'm like, "How are you moving so fast?
You're gonna get these wrong.
You're gonna fail."
And then he passed with like a 73
and then it showed him all of his answers.
And I was like, well,
let me scroll over here.
Oh, no.
Just let me, you know, I don't want to...
I just wanna like see if what I'm thinking
is the right answer.
Your certification is about
to be stripped from you, sir.
I'm just saying, well, of
course, I didn't do it.
I just thought about it.
Okay.
All right.
Thanks for clarifying.
I didn't go over there and actually verify
that his answers agreed with mine,
but I bet you that they
did if I would've checked.
What'd you get on the test?
A 91.
Okay.
Well, okay.
It helps to, you know what?
I'm not even going to say anything.
Yeah.
It just helps to be knowledgeable.
I don't want you to be
stripped of your license.
But dude, I mean, they spend
very, very, very little time
in this course talking about
how amazing scuba diving is.
Matter of fact, there's basically
no part of the curriculum
that says, "Remember how awesome this is."
So by the time I got to the end of it,
all I learned was that like,
you can die in a million different ways.
You can mame your body and be in all types
of internal pain.
I mean, the one thing that
put me at ease was like,
all right, I have a fear of
holding my breath underwater.
But one of the first things
you learn in scuba class
is never hold your breath.
Yeah.
You don't hold your breath.
You're breathing the whole time.
Because not just because you have air,
but because the further you go down,
the more pressure gets on your lungs.
And if you hold your
breath under pressure,
and then you start to ascend,
your lungs become a closed system
when you're holding your breath.
And then all those little balloons-
It's like a paper bag.
All those little balloons,
the air inside starts
to expand your freaking lungs explode.
That's not good.
Your freaking lungs explode.
So you have to have a discipline
to be constantly breathing.
How deep does that become an issue at?
I don't know.
They don't want you
knowing the exceptions.
And maybe I did know, but
I can't remember that.
But not pool depth?
Not pool depth.
No, not like eight or 10 feet.
Okay.
Don't ask me questions that then I'm like,
don't listen to any of my facts
that I'm stating about scuba.
Well, the one thing I'm a
little bit worried about
is there's so many numbers involved
and there's like math
and there's calculations.
Oh gosh.
Yeah.
Because you got all this nitrogen-
And your life depends on it.
You get this nitrogen that has to off-gas.
And so depending on how deep you are,
you have to do all these calculations
and keep all these records.
You're gonna need a laminated chart.
Like they make for the gut check episodes
that you take down and dive with.
Either that or like a dive computer
that does it all for you.
That exists?
Yeah.
Get that.
I can rent one of those.
But if you have to, but it's really, okay.
I can't dive past like
60-feet for more than an hour.
I'm just throwing out numbers here.
But then if you want to go-
You're gonna be 60 feet under the water?
How does that make you feel?
Well, I'll tell you how it made me feel
when I did the next level of training.
But yeah, they're talking about like,
you got all this nitrogen in your body
and it has to off-gas and it
will accumulate over time.
So if you don't wait
24 hours after a dive,
you have to calculate how
deep you can go for how long
in any subsequent dives in like
in the same 24-hour period.
Think of all the people who
learned this the hard way.
Yeah.
So you don't come up too
and you don't get the bends.
And then-
Is that a TikTok dance?
It's the name of an album.
You then move to the next phase,
which is you get training in a pool.
So we did this at our pool.
It was just me, Lincoln,
and Matt, and Rey.
They were supervising, the two of them
were supervising our training.
And so we spent like four
and a half hours in my pool
this past weekend, learning how to dive.
With the breathing apparatus,
and the tanks, and everything?
Yeah, with the full kit and caboodle.
Wetsuit?
Oh yeah, wetsuit and everything.
Wetsuit, hood, boots, gloves,
everything that I'm gonna
have for the next phase,
which is going into the open
ocean water certification,
which is two days, I'm doing
that this coming weekend.
Oh gosh.
I think I am.
Nice knowing you.
So this past weekend we get
in the pool and they're like,
first of all, it's like even snorkeling,
when you put your face under the water,
like everything in your being
is telling you don't breathe.
I mean you're underwater, do not breathe.
That's why you can throw a baby in water.
Yeah.
It's instinct that you have to overcome
that you have to start
breathing underwater.
And it's pretty nerve-wracking.
I mean, if you've ever snorkeled,
there's like that moment of acclimation.
That's like, "Oh, yes,
body, you can do this.
Chill out brain, you can do this."
Then you put on the regulator.
Yeah.
It's an amazing system that
you're putting this vest on
that then it connects
to the tank behind you
as well as you having a
regulator that you breathe
the air out of the tank and
a backup octopus regulator
that you can share with
somebody in an emergency
or use yourself.
Or share with an octopus.
They don't need it.
But then there's also a hose
that you hook to the vest
because you wear this vest
and you put weights in it,
depending on how much you weigh,
you've gotta be able to sink.
So you weigh yourself down
even more than just the tank
and the vest, just ballast.
And that's how you get back up.
You fill the vest with more air.
Yes.
You have this trigger over here.
I always wondered about that.
Instead of breathing the air in,
it is pressurized and it
fills up your vest like a PFD
and you can fill it up
a little bit at a time.
And it's so interesting-
And then you can let it
a little bit at a time.
When it goes into your vest,
so you got the pressurized,
you know, mixture, whatever is in there.
And then when it goes into the vest,
it creates a buoyancy that
wasn't a force that was existing
when it was pressurized.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I didn't know about this.
I always kind of thought that
they like dropped weights
or something.
I knew they didn't, but I don't know like
how do you get back up?
Yeah.
The air mixture, which there's, you know,
the air we breathe is mostly nitrogen.
Yeah.
So that's why when you're down at depth,
The nitrogen content
in your body increases.
Do you have to like
dial in what the mix is?
No, no, no.
It's all predetermined?
Yeah.
It's just a tank.
You breathe out of it.
Okay.
You suck it down.
So yeah, there's this thing
that we had to learn was
getting in the pool.
I mean everything.
How do you put on fins
without killing yourself?
How do you put on your goggles, You know,
in a way that they-
And then they fall back into the water,
is that what you did?
Did you do that inside the pool?
Well, we walk into the pool.
We did one of those like
long step into the pool,
but we didn't do the like backflip
off the side of a dingy into the pool.
You'll do that next time?
You'll do that this weekend?
That's the one thing that I,
I don't know.
Oh you're like, "I don't
wanna do the back clip thing."
But over the course of the four hours,
like the first thing to do is all right,
you're gonna start breathing underwater.
Let's go down and sit on
the bottom of the pool.
And, you know, they
say, breath constantly.
You gotta like breathe calmly in and out.
And then I get down in there
and I'm just starting to breathe.
I mean, there's a little bit of,
you have to like suck the air
out of the tank a little bit.
It kind of feels that way.
Like, it's a restricted flow of air.
It's not just like breathing
air right here right now.
There's a little resistance.
You gotta coax it out.
And then your brain is still telling you,
this is not a good idea.
This is a bad idea.
This is a life-ending
idea to breathe down here
under this water.
Don't do it.
And so at a certain point,
very early on for me,
that sensation started to creep back in,
and then he's like, come
up, telling me thumbs up.
So I come back up.
He could tell?
No, he's like, "How you doing?"
I'm like, "I'm doing pretty good.
Just taking an adjustment."
He's like, "You guys are doing great.
Now we're gonna fill up your
mask halfway with water."
And I'm gonna teach you
how to get all the water
outta your mask without coming up for air.
Yeah, this is it.
Without coming up to the surface.
I mean, basically, you
have to learn everything
that could go wrong or
make you uncomfortable
or need adjustment that you can fix it
without giving in to the
urge to try to come up
to the surface.
'Cause again, you're 30, 60-feet down.
You have to get rid of
this notion of, well,
I gotta go to the surface
to take care of this.
Right.
No, no, no.
You gotta take care of it right there.
How's Lincoln doing at this point?
Better than me.
Okay.
I just wanted to make sure.
So, he taught us how to clear the mask,
but we go underwater, he points at me
and he like does a mask sign,
like fill up your mask with water.
So, you seal the top of the mask.
Well, first of all, you let
water in the top of the mask.
You just kinda like take it off.
And then it fills out with water.
You can fill it up halfway if you wanted
to kind of ease into it.
And then you put the mask back on.
You're like, okay, now you
seal the top of the mask
against your forehead.
And you look up towards the surface
and you raise the bottom of the mask out.
And blow?
And blow and then you
blow outta your nose.
Yeah.
Which of course is part of the mask.
And then the air from your nose
fills up the top of the mask
and down, down, down,
forcing all the water out
and then you can put the mask back on.
It's a freaking magic trick.
Did you know this?
I didn't know it, but
before you explained it,
I would have guessed
that that's what you did.
Yeah.
But you've never done
it, when you've snorkeled
you've never done it.
No, 'cause I haven't been-
Yeah.
'Cause, you can come up
to the surface and clear,
and we also had to learn
to clear your snorkel
and stuff I didn't know.
But the first time I did that,
like my mask is filled up with water.
I'm opening my eyes in my pool.
I'm like, "I don't like to
open my eyes in my pool."
And then I'm like, "Oh,
I forgot to breathe."
And then I take a big
deep breath and I'm like,
and then like my lungs are filled with air
and I breathe out just a little bit.
And then I breathe in again.
And all of a sudden I'm
like having this panic-
Why are you making me panic
by telling your story?
Like you're in the pool.
Because it was freaking scary.
'Cause I was like, I
packed my lungs with air
and I just felt like I kept
trying to pack more air in there
and I started panicking and
then it's like I had to come up
and then I was, you know,
took a breath at the surface
and then I was like, "All right,
I gotta get this under control.
I gotta calm down."
And I talked to my instructor about it
and he gave me some tips about like,
make sure you breathe
out, empty your lungs.
Like breathe out all the way
before you start breathing in again.
And I just had to start telling myself,
"Doesn't matter what
happens with your mask
or anything like that.
As long as you're breathing,
you can handle everything else
and you don't need to get
worked up here, stay calm."
It's a meditative exercise of
discipline to train your brain
and your instincts to
turn off in certain ways
and to stay chill.
Because you know, even
if you start sucking down
a lot of air, it's just gonna
limit the amount of time
you're able to enjoy your dive anyway,
'cause you're gonna run outta air.
Or die from panic.
I gotta say, I'm a
little worried about you.
I got used to that.
And then he is like, "Now we're
gonna lose your regulator.
You're gonna lose the thing
that is keeping you alive.
You're gonna lose the hose."
And then he taught us how to find it
and put it back in our mouths.
And like, that was scary 'cause like now
I am holding my breath and he's like,
"Don't hold your breath,
you have to be breathing out constantly."
So I'm breathing out
assuming that I'm gonna find
the regulator to put back in my mouth.
Okay.
So you're saying that you
can't hold your breath
at any point because even if
you're not moving vertical-
You technically can but
when you're learning
you need to develop a discipline
of constantly breathing.
Just so you don't forget, make
it a reflex kind of thing.
Yeah.
'Cause when you're panicking
and if you have to do
an emergency ascent to the surface-
You wanna keep it coming out.
You have to keep your
airway open by breathing out
so that your lungs don't explode.
So we did that and like put in a regulator
and then it's like practice
losing your regulator
and then using your backup regulator.
And now it's like, all
right, now let's practice
the symbol for I'm out of air,
which is like slitting
your own throat symbol.
And so then it's like Lincoln
and I had to rescue each other
underwater by sharing our
air with the other guy-
Ew, gross.
From the, no you keep it
regulator in your mouth,
but you've got a backup
that you haven't used.
The one for the octopus?
Yeah.
The octopus you put on the
other guy and you link up
and you do the hand
signals like you're okay
And then you ascend.
Hold on.
Was that white power?
No.
Okay.
I'm just making sure.
The okay symbol is, thumbs
up does not mean okay.
Thumbs up means go to the surface
and I did not learn any racist symbols.
I'm just making sure I
don't know this company
that you're dealing with.
I'm just looking out for everything.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I made sure that I wasn't working
with a racist scuba company.
Good.
It is important.
That's I mean, just as
important as not dying.
And then we had to
practice rescuing someone
who's potentially dead at the bottom.
Who got to do that?
Rey played dead at the bottom of the pool.
This is Rey's favorite part.
Rey is a she.
You know, think like star wars.
Oh, R-E-Y?
R-E-Y.
Yeah.
Mythical Beasts too, turns out.
Oh wow.
Yeah.
She told me that after I saved
her life a couple of times.
First time I saved her life
I got a cramp in my calf
and I just let her go.
And I went into like fix my cramp mode
and then I had to retrieve
her from the bottom again.
Is there a symbol for cramp?
No.
There's just a technique.
You grab the end of your fin
and pull it towards your knee
to stretch it out.
Okay.
And then I got her up and I was like,
"Hey, listen, if you are already dead,
I'm at least gonna handle my cramp."
She's like, "Actually
you did the right thing."
You're supposed to take
care of yourself before you-
Yeah, it's like being on a plane.
Yep.
Before you take care of somebody else.
Oxygen to yourself.
So it's all of this
learn to just stay cool,
honey bunny, no matter what happens,
'cause you're gonna be underwater
and you ain't gonna not be underwater.
And if you're panicking
and sucking down air,
it's like, you have to learn.
So by the end of five hours, he was like,
"You guys are fast learners.
We're gonna go out to Catalina.
We're gonna spend two
days in the open water.
You're gonna get your certification."
And I'm thinking.
Sharks.
I don't care about sharks.
I'm not afraid of sharks.
Okay.
I'm just letting you know
they'll be out there.
Some people are that.
I'm not that.
I'm just afraid of suffocating.
Okay.
So I'm thinking to myself,
I'm not ready, I'm not ready,
but I kept the equipment
in between the last time.
Oh, so you're contemplating not going
because of your-
The first time I panicked,
that I told you about,
I definitely had a thought
of, I can't do this.
We've already booked our
trip to go out to Catalina
to get certified.
We've already booked our trips in Hawaii.
I've really built this up.
You can't you can't back out now.
I can't do it.
And then I'm like, I can't back out now.
It's like this in and of itself is a test.
I can do this.
I just need to chill out.
And that was like in the first 30 minutes,
like the first time I
was breathing underwater.
So it got better.
I can only imagine how hairing
your story is going to be
when you leave the pool.
I know, man.
Yeah.
I don't think you, you would
not have any trouble with this.
And I asked Lincoln
last night, I was like,
"Dude, were you panicking at any point?"
He was like that one time your
mask filled up with water,
you did shoot to the surface.
He was like, "Yeah, but after
that I was totally cool."
I was like, "You're too
young to think about dying."
The main issue I would have
is the issue that I have
while snorkeling is my beard.
And people say, "Oh, you
put the silicone stuff
or whatever."
But like, I've tried it and
my mask leaks and you know me,
I'm not losing the beard.
No, just all you'd have to
do is shave your mustache.
Yeah.
You know, me, Amish Rhett.
You would have to be Amish.
If I make a commitment
to the Amish lifestyle,
I'll become a scuba diver,
but that might be a conflict.
I don't know if they
believe in that technology.
Last night, I said, "Lincoln,
let's get back in the pool
and practice one more time."
There's some air left in our tanks.
And we got in, I spent
probably an hour and a half
in the pool last night,
losing my regulator,
holding my breath underwater, and like,
well, breathing out while I
try to recover my air supply
and just laying at the bottom of a pool.
And just trying to put
myself in that mental space
of if you get worked up, just breath,
just calm your breathing.
So I feel more comfortable
after doing that.
And I also know now what it feels like
to run out of air, because
I practiced until literally
the tank was empty, which
that's a scary feeling.
So I go up to Lincoln and I'm
like, mine ran out before his,
and I'm like doing the symbol.
And he's like, we actually did it.
I took his and we, but
it's a scary feeling
when you're sucking your air.
And it's getting more difficult
then all of a sudden it's,
there's nothing.
Is there any sort of warning?
No, you just have a gauge.
Well, there's a gauge.
There's a gauge that you're
constantly monitoring.
But I've forgotten totally
about why I got into this.
So I'm trying to get back into that space.
And I hope when I go to Catalina
that it's gonna be a beautiful experience.
That's gonna be like, yes,
this is why I was doing this.
'Cause, all I've been thinking about
is worst-case scenarios.
Well, it's not gonna be Fiji.
Just so you understand that.
Like, I mean-
He said there could be-
I've seen like beautiful
videos for people who have dove
around Catalina, but it's not Fiji,
where you're in an aquarium.
Yeah.
It's not gonna be that great.
So I've just kind of talked
about all of the stuff
that's made me really scared,
but I'm balancing that
with the experiences
that I'm gonna have with
my son and with nature.
So he's not nervous?
Not nervous.
No.
So he's a good buddy, I was like,
"Lincoln, if I start doing this,
Zen, breath in, breathe
out symbol with my hands,
it means that I'm panicking.
Don't try to get me to do anything else.
Just come over and just like smile."
Is that part of the training?
No, that's something I developed.
Okay.
Maybe they'll add it to the curriculum.
Man.
So we'll get to your
near-death experiences,
but I've gotta talk about
Dispatchers From Myrtle Beach.
Yeah.
Have we talked about
Dispatchers from Myrtle beach
on this show?
Not on this show.
I don't know if we-
We talked about it on GMM this week.
We've announced it.
And I mean, I just
listened to the trailer,
Which is out.
For this podcast,
which is Charles Neal and Link Neal.
That's Link's dad.
And let me just tell you,
I mean, I'm very excited.
I know that you've already
recorded an episode.
Yeah.
But I mean, when?
Well, it comes out this Thursday.
When you just, I mean your dad-
Or last Thursday, if your
watching the video version.
Your dad's voice is iconic.
And now we're monetizing it.
He has been so excited.
Once I started talking to
him about doing a podcast
and I'm like, "Dad, this is your podcast.
And I'm just like your sidekick.
I'm just here to talk to
you and catch up every week,
every Thursday we're gonna
publish our conversation
where we catch up."
But there's gonna be, we have
different segments planned,
different things that
he's gonna talk about.
So yeah, he's driving the ship
and I'm an interesting
passenger on this journey
of what is this gonna become something?
And I think it really comes down to,
is it gonna become
something in my dad's mind
and in his life?
Is this gonna legitimately
be an outlet for him?
Like so far, he's got hundreds
and hundreds of emails
from people ever since way back
when I tweeted his email address,
people didn't believe me.
And then he is like elated to be getting,
"I got 300 emails."
He's about to get more.
"In one night."
Yeah.
ratherbshaggin53@aol.com.
This his email address.
So yeah, every Thursday,
wherever you get your podcast,
Dispatches From Myrtle Beach.
My dad has a podcast where he talks to me.
So go over there and subscribe and follow,
whatever you can do, even
though an episode's not out
if you're listening to this,
but if you're watching the
video, the episode's up,
the first episode's up.
You can go and actually
listen to it right now,
wherever you get your podcast.
The things that we talked
about in the first episode,
I ended up giving him quite an education.
Of course, I learned some
things about him too.
I don't want to give anything away.
I just want you to go over there.
I'm excited about this.
I haven't listened to it,
I'm gonna listen to it as a consumer.
You know what I'm saying?
We're trying to the
episodes at like 30 minutes.
So it's kind of feels a different niche
in your listening routine
than say Ear Biscuits.
So yeah.
Thursdays, Dispatchers From Myrtle Beach.
Let's start with hearing
a near-death experience.
So this is actually a very American story.
I almost choked to death on a
corner of a hot sauce packet
while eating lunch at work.
Oh.
I ripped it off.
That's not it?
And I guess I didn't
throw it away properly.
And it somehow made its
way into my sandwich.
And when I tried to swallow,
it got stuck in my esophagus
or whatever it is that blocks,
stuff that isn't supposed to
be going into your stomach.
Well, you, oh no, it
blocked your windpipe.
And I was all alone.
I had my own office and no one was around.
I had a walkie-talkie,
but couldn't use it
because I couldn't speak
because I was choking and
I had no clue what to do.
I ended up trying to
dig it outta my throat.
It didn't quite work.
And I ended up just trying
to make myself throw up
and that did work.
So I did not die.
And I lived to tell the tale,
but that's the story of me being American
and almost choking to death on something
that could have been prevented
if I had just not been
so hasty while I was eating.
Thanks for sharing your story.
But there's a couple of, I just
can't believe this happened.
I mean typically the corner
of a hot sauce packet
is not a chokable size.
It depends on how good of a rip you get
and how deep it goes, I think.
And if it just went into the windpipe,
she said esophagus but-
Trachea.
Trachea and the esophagus,
right, they meet.
It must have been at a spot where,
'cause making yourself throw up
is gonna bypass your windpipe
if it's gone deep enough.
Well, it's probably right
there at the intersection
of the two.
And I don't know, I'm no doctor,
but I think that if something
is lodged right there
at the top of the trachea,
it's more than anything.
it's super unpleasant.
But if you were to stop and not cough,
you would find that you're still able to,
especially in this case,
get oxygen into your lungs.
Now I'm not a doctor either.
Yeah.
But my understanding is-
But you've taken that scuba test.
You do not give someone
the Heimlich Maneuver
if they're making noise,
because that means that there
is some sort of airflow.
Well, if they're like.
They're beating a table,
that's noise just to clarify.
If there's no noise.
Right.
It's like, you must be silent,
calm down and don't say a word
or make a sound before I do the Heimlich.
If they're coughing and making noise.
If there's still air
coming from their lungs
in some capacity.
Right, then there's not
a complete blockage.
And it won't work.
You'll just break their ribs or whatever.
Again, not a doctor.
This is not medical advice.
In the event of choking,
go to Google and figure out
what you're supposed to
do or do that right now
and then be ready for when it happens.
The American part of it, like she said-
Hotsauce packet.
So Americans are associated
with hot sauce packets.
I mean, I'm sure they've
ventured out beyond America,
but it, I think that it was like
this super convenient
little pack of something
and this disposable thing, you
know, it feels very American.
It's interesting that
it was in the sandwich
and that's the foreign
object in the sandwich
is what made her choke.
But any part of the sandwich
could have made her choke.
But she knew it was the hot sauce.
I guess so.
The hot sauce packets, I mean,
it's gonna grab on in a way
that food is not gonna grab on.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm not a doctor.
This is disturbing.
Let's go to another one.
Hi, Rhett and Link.
My name is Jacqueline and
my near-death experience
was when my boyfriend at the time,
who was now my husband left me alone
at his apartment complex,
while I was there,
I heard a really loud chainsaw
noise and it was so loud.
And I heard girls outside
my apartment screaming,
bloody murder.
And I thought there was a
chainsaw man on the loose.
I even filmed it.
I have a video of myself
wondering where the chainsaw
was coming from.
And I, in the moment, did
not think to call the police
or do anything rational.
But I ran out of the
apartment without my shoes on,
down three flights of stairs
jumped into my car, and drove
and parked in the nearest
Piggly Wiggly parking lot.
When I got back after sobbing,
thinking I almost died
from a chainsaw attack.
I found out it was a man
doing donuts on his motorcycle
in the parking.
And I literally thought I
was going to get chainsawed
to death.
So that was my near-death experience.
Man doing donuts.
Yeah.
I think she was, chainsaw
man, man doing donuts.
I will say, I think the
Piggly Wiggly parking lot
is maybe not the safest
place to on the planet.
I mean, I think there's...
No.
Listen, not a sponsor.
I hope maybe Piggly Wiggly
will sponsor us at some point,
but just based on my Piggly
Wiggly parking lot experiences,
you know what being at
home is probably safer.
Yeah.
I've watched a Piggly Wiggly
burn to the ground before
that one in Wilmington.
You were present for that?
Yeah.
I just walked over to the edge
of Nana and Papa's neighborhood
and sat on a berm and
just watched it burn.
You're joking.
Nah.
Don't you remember when that happened?
I remember hearing about
it, but I didn't see it.
I remember driving by afterwards.
You know, typically when
somebody like arsonist,
this is the type of thing they do.
Yeah.
Look at that little
teenager sitting on a berm,
watching the Piggly Wiggly
burn, suspect number one.
The Chief of Police's grandson.
Yeah.
It all adds up.
Wasn't me.
Hold on.
Did you burn it down?
I didn't, for the record I did not burn
the Piggly Wiggly down.
Do you think somebody did?
Was it arson?
No, it wasn't arson.
As far as I recall.
We had a lot of arson in our parts.
Hearing a chainsaw immediately thinking
of a chainsaw man is, you know,
that's kind of a leap.
The screams though.
The screams.
Yeah.
That's scary.
And now that we do
understand what was happening
and it was a donut man,
not a chainsaw man.
Doing donuts.
Were the screams, screams of glee?
Yeah.
'Cause that's a good way
to get a Harnett County woman excited.
I don't know what this was.
In a Piggly Wiggly parking lot,
there is no way to get a woman
more excited, more quickly.
"Can you do a donut?"
Yeah.
Now it does remind me of
Lincoln's gotten into manga
and he was reading.
I was like, "Let me look at
this one that you're reading?"
He was like, "Okay, it's
called Chainsaw Man."
Whoa.
And I just started
flipping through the book
and he's like, "First of all,
you're flipping backwards."
You gotta start from the back.
You gotta start from the back, yeah.
And I was like, "Well, spoiler alert."
It's the most disturbingly,
well-illustrated,
disturbing scenes I've ever seen.
Like the creatures, there's this creature
called Santa Claus.
That has nothing to do with Santa Claus.
That then like is an amalgamation
of all of these things
that it like starts to control,
like baby doll heads, they
group into like the legs
of a spider creature
that is walking around.
Oh, it's like one of those,
what do we call the
things where you just have
eyeballs and hair?
Oh, you love this type of stuff.
You would really be into it.
But the Chainsaw Man-
You can have one of those.
Is a guy that I don't
know what triggers it.
It's a very famous manga
written and illustrated
by Tatsuki Fujimoto.
So this is in Japanese?
So he's just looking at the
pictures or is it translated?
I think it's translated.
I was just looking at the pictures.
It's mostly pictures.
So then when they translate
it, they don't also flip it?
No.
The Chainsaw man, it's like when he turns
into Chainsaw Man a chainsaw
comes out of his head
and out of his hands
and it destroys his body
as he's transforming.
And it's very grotesque.
Quite a sacrifice.
It's very grotesque.
And there's a video
series that's coming out.
Well, I hope so.
He's very excited about it.
I was like, "I don't know if
I can watch that with you.
It's gonna be scary, man."
What is it like to be
a child and have a dad
who is the one that gets scared
of scuba diving and manga?
It's scary, man.
What is that gonna do for him as grows up?
It's legitimately disturbing.
I was like, "Son, doesn't
this disturb you?"
I think he's in the wrong.
I was like, "If this
doesn't disturb you..."
No, it's cool, man.
It's cool.
It's troubling to me.
It's troubling to me, but
I'll watch it with him.
I'll give it a shot.
Hey guys, my name's Amber,
about four years ago
during a nice thunderstorm,
I went outside to record the
water coming down the road.
There was a lightning strike really close,
I don't remember much, but I ran inside
and watched the video back to see
that it was like right next to me,
and slowing it down
frame-by-frame is even scarier.
And I haven't been out
during thunderstorm since.
I still have the video of
y'all wanna see it too.
And I don't really know if
it's considered near-death,
but it was definitely scary.
So, yeah.
Thanks, bye-bye.
Well, we're watching the video
and I can tell you right now.
Yeah.
This is near-death.
Turn this sound onto Amber's video.
@menjiepoo, M-E-N-J-I-E, poo with two OS.
Okay.
All this water, guys.
It's awesome.
We could freaking tube down...
All this water, guys.
It's awesome.
We could freaking tube down.
Wow.
"All this water."
"Water."
I like the way she said that.
Obviously, she's just being funny but...
We can freaking tube down this, Amber.
Amber was so excited about
the ability to tube
down that creek, ditch.
Wow
Good Lord.
So see if you can, it lights
up like half the screen.
Go back to there and kind of
do the frame-by-frame thing
she was talking about.
I don't know if you can
do that with Twitter,
but basically oh, like, whoa.
I mean it phases out the camera on the...
but look, it's like lighting up the whole-
It's pink.
It's very pink.
Wow.
That's crazy.
That is crazy.
And she screamed at the same time it hit.
The tube...
"Water."
"All this water."
Amber, we like when you say water.
Oh, wow.
Thank you, Amber.
And then she said, "I left a voicemail
and I think I talked too fast."
No, we like it when you talk fast.
No.
Yeah, that's good.
Keep it short.
Keep it sweet.
Wow.
Yeah man.
Glad you're okay, Amber.
I think that I miss thunderstorms.
I seem to remember like the baddest,
scariest thunderstorms
happen when we were at church
on like a Wednesday night,
there'd be pink lightning.
When you got that pink lightning.
Only at church?
I just have those memories.
Yeah.
They happen quite a bit.
Hi, Rhett and Link.
My name is Jacob and I'm from
Charlotte, North Carolina.
And my near-death experience
happened on the second week
of my freshman year at college
at Western Carolina
University up in Cullowhee,
near Asheville.
A group of friends and I went
up to a waterfall one Saturday
and I was not being particularly wise
as I was walking on some
rocks on top of a waterfall.
So of course, I slipped
and I fell on my stomach
down one small waterfall and then another,
until I fortunately, landed in a pool
deep enough to stop me,
about a small cars width
from a 50-foot drop
to just a pile of rocks.
To make matters worse,
The pool I landed in
was full of leeches and
they were all over my legs,
all the way up my swimsuit.
Oh.
And one last thing,
I was with a group of friends
from a campus ministry
I was in at the time,
I have a similar
deconstruction story to y'alls.
And the guy that helped
pick the leeches off my legs
kept complaining about how weird it was
and how uncomfortable it made him.
So that was a great Saturday.
Yeah.
That, getting a little homoerotic there.
Little uncomfortable for the...
Is that what was happening?
I think it was,
it was just like, oh.
No, I just kind of think pulling leeches
off somebody is weird.
Spirituality aside, like
belief system aside.
I think, my understanding was why
he would made the connection
is if the guy was a little uncomfortable
with getting close to
his junk or something.
Dude, freaking going off of a water.
You gotta be freaking careful, man.
If you're like hanging
out around a waterfall
and if you're in the
water that then starts to
eventually falls.
It's just not a good practice.
You don't wanna be in
pre-waterfall water, you know?
Yeah.
It just seems like something to live by.
I don't swim in pre-waterfall water.
The most visceral this
has ever been for me
was when we visited Niagara Falls.
And so there's been
plenty of times in my life
when I've been like in
a creek or in a river
that had a waterfall and
you're like kind of swimming
and you're like, I'm not gonna go there
because it's a waterfall.
Yeah.
But one time we were swimming at Yosemite
when I was a kid.
I remember this very clearly
because my dad was like,
"There's a waterfall down there."
And then years later we heard about people
who would be swimming in Yosemite
and get swept down and go off
a giant waterfall and die.
Yeah.
The year that I was
there, we hiked to the top
of Yosemite Falls and they
were doing a helicopter rescue
of someone who had gone over the falls.
Yeah.
But when we went to Niagara falls,
when we visited Niagara
falls with our wives.
Yeah.
And we were on the Canadian side.
Right?
Which is the better side.
Nothing against America, but
just, it's a cooler side.
More picturesque, I believe.
Of the river.
It's crazy.
You can get right down there next to 'em.
You can't really if I remember correctly,
you can't like walk to it or
whatever, if you're just a,
you know, a civilian, but obviously
you don't want to go off Niagara Falls.
And just the other day I
saw a video going around,
I think on Twitter.
And it was the guy who cuts the grass.
What?
Above the Falls.
And he's got a rope tied to him.
So like the person who's
like mowing the grass.
Is he on a riding lawnmower?
with a rope attached to him?
In my mind he had a push mower
because it was a place
you didn't wanna be like
on a vehicle that could fall in.
It was just like, Okay, I'm
kind of mowing the grass here."
Oh wow.
"And I'm buckled in."
Here we go.
There you go.
There he is right there.
Dude, using a push mower.
And he is got like this giant-
Yeah.
That makes sense.
Harness around him.
And a sleeveless shirt.
Well, you don't want to be weighed down.
I think he's just wearing...
That's a mow job I don't want.
Really?
Extra challenging though.
That's beautiful though.
That's advanced mowing.
People go, yeah.
There was the person who drove their car
and was like the car
with the person in it,
was like close to the
edge of Niagara Falls,
like a few months ago.
And they had to do a
rescue to get the person
out of the car.
They were in the water?
Yeah.
And yeah.
I guess if your car is up there
don't get out of your car.
I don't think they were conscious.
'Cause then you're in serious trouble.
Good gracious.
I mean, yeah.
Imagine going over a
waterfall landing in a pool
and then struggling, but
then Jacob went over again,
landing in a second pool
and then he finally got it together.
'Cause if he'd gone over that third one
he would've been in a
thousand pieces, man.
Well, and then yeah, pool full of leeches
and a uncomfortable moment with a friend.
Man.
My bizarre near-death experience happened
when I had to get foot
surgery on my big toe.
They thought it was a bone
infection or something like that.
So went in for the surgery
at an outpatient center,
proceeded to apparently
go into anaphylactic shock
on the table, allergic to
some of the medications
they gave me for the surgery.
I woke up, was told about it
and I was the outpatient
center's first code blue ever.
So that is my bizarre
near-death experience
that my big toe tried to kill me.
Dang.
I mean, that's scary.
'Cause this is a group of doctors
who are not accustomed
necessarily to dealing with-
Outpatients.
Yeah.
You know, code blue.
It's like, we're just gonna
take care of your toe.
I mean just makes me think.
Every time they ask me, "Are
you allergic to anything?"
It's just like, I always brush it off.
"Of course not, pollen?"
When I was little, my mom would say,
"He's allergic to amoxicillin
because as a baby,
he had a little reaction to it."
But then at a certain point,
I just stopped saying that.
Well, when was the time
you had antibiotics?
I don't know.
Many years.
'Cause I mean, there's still
a big class of antibiotics.
Maybe ten years.
I mean, it might be worth finding out.
But usually what will happen
is you're not gonna die.
Like you'll be in like
the first or second day
of taking them usually.
And then you'll be like,
this happens to Jesse.
She'd be like, "Oh I'm reacting to this."
Yeah.
And then you just stop
and get on another one.
I had toe surgery.
It's the only surgery I've ever had.
When you broke your toe
after the basketball game.
No, ingrown toenail.
Oh, you got that?
I had an ingrown toenail in high school
and went to the podiatrist
and still the one of the toe,
I got some messed up toenails in general,
but one of 'em on my big toe.
Like you can kind of
tell that what they do
is so that it...
One side of, one of my big toes.
Oh no.
Doesn't go under the skin.
The nail doesn't meet the skin.
You gotta learn how to scuba dive
and you gotta take this
kind of stuff, man.
And so they did something
where they like cut it
so that it would, and I was fully awake
and it was just like numbed or whatever,
no code blues for me.
But yeah, that's the one surgery
I've had, is toe surgery.
Big toe surgery.
That's what we've got in common.
It's so interesting to wake
up from an outpatient surgery
and they say, "Oh, you died for a second."
It's like, "What?"
Like, "My toe died for a second?
No, you died for a second."
Well, this is kind of
crazy, for two reasons.
Two things that I've
been looking into lately,
the first is I just happened
to see a article yesterday.
And it was like a collection of people
who woke up during
surgery and their stories.
God.
See, I wonder if we're
gonna get the numbers back
on this episode and be
like, "No one's listening
to this episode 'cause
they're smarter than I am."
No.
I didn't realize that I
didn't want to hear this.
Well, here's the thing, you
don't like Chainsaw Man,
but there's a market for it.
Okay.
I'm in the market for it.
And I'm speaking right now.
Why are you reading about
people waking up during surgery?
'Cause I have a fear of that happening.
But then why read about it?
To know how bad it's
gonna be, to be prepared.
So you're convinced it's
gonna happen to you.
It wasn't as bad as I...
I mean, there was a couple
people who were like,
"It was the worst pain
I've ever experienced.
Nothing has ever come close."
But there was a couple people
who were like, "I woke up,
everybody saw me, they
gave me a little bit more
of the juice and I went back to sleep."
I won't go into any
more details about that.
But the second thing
I've been reading about-
So you're telling me
it made you feel better
reading about those things.
I feel the same.
The second thing I've been reading about,
and I find it interesting that
we didn't get any of these
and Daniel is it that
we didn't get any at all
or that they're not in these
ones that we're selecting from
in terms of people who
actually like saw something.
Like saw the light?
Saw the light.
Okay.
No one in the Mythical Beast
community has seen the light.
And I wouldn't say that I am like going,
I haven't gone hardcore
like deep into this,
but I'm finding myself
reading about and watching
documentaries about people's
near-death experiences
and actually experiencing
like out of body stuff.
I mean, I still don't know
what I think about it.
I'm in an open place.
Is it like, okay, this is just something
where there's like DMT
released in your brain
when you die and you feel
like this is what's happening?
Yeah.
But it's pretty fascinating how...
I was actually hoping we would
get some of those submissions
based on some of the
stuff I've been reading,
'Cause they are relatively common
and there's all these
scientists, you know,
people who had like a
completely materialistic,
naturalistic view of the world
where they're like, "Consciousness
is completely contained in the mind."
Who basically began looking into this
and were like, "I can't
in good conscience,
continue to believe that that's the case.
Something else must be going
on with all these things
that are happening to people."
And of course, this is not anything new
people have been talking
about this forever,
but I don't know.
It was a little intriguing.
My granddad, so my mom's dad, you know,
he passed away in 1996.
Oh, I remember that.
I mean, he had two separate
open heart surgery procedures,
like where they split you
open, at least back then,
from sternum down your thigh.
The scar that he had is just
like crazy train tracks.
Why do they have to go so deep?
I don't know.
It's like trying to open a
book and you really just gotta.
You gotta keep ripping it.
Yeah, right.
You gotta keep ripping.
You gotta stretch the spine out.
Oh, nasty.
I actually don't know if it was related
to the second one of
those or something else,
but I definitely remember sitting
at the kitchen table after,
while he was recovering.
And he said that when he was under and he,
I don't remember if
they said that he coded
for any period of time.
This is not the type of story
that you want to go back to
and talk to relatives about
when you're just shooting the breeze.
But he described going to a place
that was like a ultra dark
warehouse, like a real creepy,
huge, dark warehouse.
So the opposite of going to the light.
And he's telling me this
story, and I'm thinking,
"Man, my Papa went to hell."
He went to the hell warehouse.
Is that like the...
I don't know.
He went to an abandoned Sam's Club.
He said he was scared.
He said it scared the shit out of him.
He start living right?
He started living right.
Yeah.
I don't know.
His jokes were always very colorful.
He kept saying, "Fart blossom."
Yeah.
But I remember being
concerned about his soul
after he told me that.
But that wasn't the implication
when he was telling it,
it was just kind of, matter
of fact, like this happened.
I was like, "What do you
do with this information?"
It seemed like not much.
Well, based on what I'm seeing,
there are things that
people have in common.
But also it's not like everyone
who is a professed Christian
sees a light and everyone who's
not sees a dark warehouse.
Yeah.
Or feels a little bit of heat.
It isn't like, "Oh no, this is supportive
of a Christian worldview."
But it's supportive of the
fact that something happens
when you get near the point of death.
And I question if consciousness
is completely contained
physically in the mind,
in the brain and that there
is no mind beyond that,
or any consciousness beyond that.
Like, what is the evolutionary advantage
of this release in this
thing that happens at death?
I mean, of course, if you're
essentially a computer
and the computer is shutting down,
some weird could happen in your mind
that then if you come back from,
that if you actually
reboot some weird shit
might be still in there.
Maybe it's just a gift.
You know, it's like the gift of existence
is that when you're transitioning,
as some people call it
or dying, as other people are calling it,
giving up the ghost, or
however you wanna say it,
that there's a little bit
of a release of something
that gives you a positive
experience, ushers you out.
But this is the thing
that's so interesting.
And we could do a whole episode on this.
Maybe we'll do a flatliners episode
where we do it to ourselves.
Maybe so you don't fight
it as much, you know.
But see, here's what I'm saying.
So I don't want you to dismiss
it if you're listening.
The thing that is they're
no longer conscious
their brain stops functioning.
This one woman was dead for 30 minutes.
Okay.
Drowned and got like a kayaking accident.
Not scuba.
Pinned underwater.
She went over a waterfall in a kayak
because somebody was in the
way, this is like episode one
of one of those Netflix series.
She goes under the water.
She's under the water.
They, basically, after 15 minutes,
it turns into a recovery operation,
not a rescue operation
because she's been underwater
for 15 minutes.
They eventually see her life jacket.
And a guy like is going
to get it to be like,
"I think her husband would want this."
And she's attached to it.
Whoops.
Pull her out.
She's blue.
Her eyes are fixed, open.
She's dead.
I don't remember exactly
how they got her to...
I think they put her on top of a kayak.
She was in Chile, I think.
Not a big bowl of chili,
the country, Chile.
And they go up the path and
there's an ambulance there.
Like some serendipitous stuff happens.
Anyway, she has all
this stuff that happens
where she basically saw
all this stuff happen
as she was like out of her
body, watching it happen.
She was a person of science.
She was a doctor.
She didn't believe any of this stuff.
She didn't have any supernatural
paranormal disposition.
Or enough kayak training.
But she spent time with
people who were very welcoming
and like, it felt awesome
and warm and everything.
And they told her you have to go back.
But they also told her basically
that her son was going to die.
What?
And so she had this feeling,
or it had been communicated to her
that her son was gonna die and
that he wouldn't make it past
his 18th birthday.
And it was on his 18th birthday,
he was in a skiing competition.
And she goes to him the night before.
And she's like, "I've never told you this,
'cause I didn't wanna freak you out.
But I don't believe you're
gonna, I think you're gonna die."
And he lives through
the skiing competition.
Then what?
Two years later he dies.
Oh, so they were off by two years.
I don't know if they told her specifically
that it wouldn't be until
18, but that's what.
Anyway, so her whole worldview has changed
and she's just one of
like thousands of people
who've had weird shit
like this happen to 'em.
Again, I don't know.
I don't know.
I hate this episode.
Why are we doing this?
But it's so interesting
that you don't like it.
All right.
So I got a near-death experience.
That's pretty comical.
Good.
And terrifying
at the same time.
Good.
Oh no.
So me and my friends, we were hiking up
Raven Cliff Falls, it's
down here in Georgia.
You guys from North Carolina
might have heard of it before.
Nope.
Heard of Georgia.
So we're hiking up the waterfall
and we've made it up the
waterfall, we already stopped.
So we're on the hike down and I slip.
I slip way up high on
this little mountain-side.
And I don't know how, somebody up there
might have been looking
out for me, not sure,
but I was able to grab a hold of a tree
and kinda maneuver my way back up.
And I get two people
come rushing out at me
and they're like, "Are you okay?
Like what's going on?"
My friend's laughing, panicking.
I'm like, "Yeah, I'm fine."
I don't realize how
bad it was until later.
And I'm brushing myself off.
I continue walking and
we get down the cliff
and my friend that was with
me, she points up at the tree
and goes, that's what saved your life.
I look up at that tree.
It's about a 200, 300-foot
fall from where that tree is.
So if that tree wasn't there.
I probably would've not be
leaving this voicemail right now.
But yeah.
So I became a tree hugger that day.
And I don't regret it.
Love your show.
Keep on keeping on and
being your Mythical best.
Hey, that was good delivery man.
And especially that tree hugger part.
That's tough, man.
If you're gonna have a
near-death experience,
it's better to not realize
it until after the fact.
Yeah.
That's the way I wanna do it.
Well, it might happen to you, man.
You're stepping into the gates of hell.
No, it's just the ocean.
Poseidon.
I'm gonna ease into it.
It's two days of being
guided into more comfort.
It's gonna be fine, Link.
Thanks.
That reminds me,
another thing that happened on that show
is that there's a series of people.
What's the name of the show?
I don't know.
So you don't even know what it's called.
"Surviving Death".
Okay.
That's the name of it.
But the other thing
that they talked about,
I'm only like two episodes
in, it's not even new.
It's been out for a while.
People falling great distances
and having these like
blissful experiences.
While falling?
It's kind of hard to understand exactly.
I think they fell great
distances and nearly died.
Like there was an impact at some point.
But they look at that experience
as the best moment of their life
because of what they experienced
in some sort of transition.
So, but I mean that can't
happen to you in the water
necessarily, but I'm sure something cool
could happen to you.
You could have a moment
that you could do a whole episode on.
Hi, Rhett, Link, and my fellow podcasters.
My name's Maddie and living in the south
with absolutely nothing to do.
I've almost died a few times,
but the funniest was
definitely when my brother
was given a go-kart
for his eighth birthday
and little three-year-old me,
he decided that we were
gonna go on a little trip
off the field and to
his benefit of the doubt
he told me to hold on and I did not.
And he took a very sharp left turn.
And according to my dad and him,
he turned left and I did not.
And I was ejected from the kart
and I just started barrel
rolling down the field,
a little three-year-old.
And apparently, my dad
was sprinting towards me
'cause I was just laying
there lifeless, alleged,
that's what they thought.
But I'm fine.
So yeah.
Thanks, guys.
Go-kart.
You bought a go-kart for your children.
Yeah, let's see.
I mean it was six years ago.
I don't have it anymore.
I sold it 'cause Lincoln
was afraid to drive it.
It was a two-seater go-kart
that my neighbor sold me
because his kids had gotten older
and it had a roll cage on
it and they wore helmets
but Lincoln had had a bad experience
riding the golf cart at my nanny's house
and he was riding it with
Lewis and Lewis fell asleep
in the golf cart.
In the gator?
In the golf cart.
Okay.
And then Lincoln hit the bird bath,
the cement bird bath, and then ran over it
and got stuck on it.
Oh, so Lincoln was driving
and his driving instructor fell asleep.
Yeah.
So he was scared to drive
the go-kart that I bought.
Kill any birds?
Nope.
No birds were bathing at the time.
That bird bath stayed teetered
over for quite a while.
Yeah.
And then Lando was not, his
legs weren't long enough
to drive it.
So I got rid of it.
But when I was a kid, Jimmy
got me and Emmy a go-kart.
Had no roll cage, no helmets,
you know, two-seater.
And we would zoom around the house
and she would be driving and
she would turn so sharply
that the whole thing rolled.
Like it didn't roll all the way over,
it like teetered all the
way up and dumped us out
and then kind of landed on top of us.
And it was like, you get
out from underneath it.
And you're like, it's
kinda like when you fall,
you're like, "Did anybody see me fall?"
"We're still good."
Turn that thing back over.
Did you have any?
Do you remember ever riding that go-kart?
I don't think I drove that go-kart.
At my house.
Because my cousins had three-wheelers.
Those are dangerous.
The first ATVs were three-wheelers.
Yeah.
And they had a little one
and they had a big one.
And I remember going down
there to South Georgia,
going to their house.
And of course, they like
just had this, just woods
and fields and stuff behind their house.
And of course, no helmet, no shoes.
I just had on a pair
of shorts and I'm six.
No instructions.
Living free, man.
They just put you on the thing.
And then they're just
like, "This is how you go."
They didn't even tell me how to stop.
And my parents are just like
inside just drinking Cokes
with my aunt and uncle.
Yeah.
It was just such a different time.
And then my other cousins,
they had a four Wheeler.
That's safer.
Well.
Doesn't roll as easily.
You can do two wheels on the front too.
Same deal though.
No helmets, I mean, boy
got away with so much,
a lot of people weren't so lucky.
Yeah.
Those are accidents waiting to happen.
Let's pick one more.
Wrap it up.
Hi, Rhett and Link.
Hey, my name is Memjay,
at the beginning of 2021,
I did something really
stupid and nearly died
when I had an accidental drug overdose.
I stopped breathing.
I couldn't move, but my thoughts
were still really clear.
Oh gosh.
And in my mind, I saw my mom's face
and I thought about how terrible
this was gonna be for her.
I saw my dog and I thought
about how much I loved her.
Oh.
And the last thing I
saw was Rhett and Link.
Hey.
Sitting behind the desk, I'd
been watching lots of GMM
at the time and it made sense.
But I had this moment in my mind
where I just laughed at the absurdity,
that my last thought in
this life was going to be
about two guys who do goofy
things on the internet,
smiling gently at me.
And it made me feel better
as everything went black,
but I didn't die.
I got to live.
And the next day when
I was trying to decide
what it all meant, I thought,
"Well, I am going to need a therapist,
a program, and a third-degree membership
in the Mythical Society."
And you comforted me when
I thought I was dying.
And it seemed the least I could do.
Wow.
So that's what I did.
And it's going really well.
And it feels good to be able
to tell you and to thank you
for your contribution to my
life and millions of others.
So thank you and love you
like a friend, fellas.
Take care.
I am so glad you're alive.
Wow.
I'm so glad that we could
be there for that moment.
I don't remember it.
I've established, I don't
know how this all works.
I'm open to the fact
that we may have somehow
been transferred to
your brain for a moment
and just smiled at you peacefully.
I don't know how it works,
but glad you're okay.
I mean, I'm honored.
I'm honored to be the last, I mean,
we could have been the last
thing that somebody thought of.
But she thought it was,
she got a laugh out.
Gotta laugh out of it.
Going and going out with a laugh.
That's good.
And then coming back
with a Third Degree
Mythical Society membership.
Yeah.
What a great advert?
Can we just use that as a commercial?
Yeah.
We say we save lives.
We appear to dying people,
bring them back so that they
can join the Mythical Society.
That is wild, man.
I mean, don't you feel honored?
I feel so honored.
It's like her life is
flashing before her eyes.
We got in there with the mom and the dog.
The final slide of her life flash is us.
Oh man.
Man, that's wild.
That is wild.
So I mean, it feels like you
got a little bit shaken up
on this episode.
I mean, I'll never watch
that Netflix series.
That's just not my type of thing.
And I'm not gonna ever find
myself reading accounts
of people waking up during surgery.
I'm sorry.
Those feel like different
things though, right.
Because if I told you the
near-death experience thing,
of course, the waking up during surgery
is just like a horrific thing.
I get it.
But the near-death experience.
There's a fascinating aspect to it.
For me, it's just I've lived a life
of just dismissing all.
And I still mostly
dismiss all of it, right.
I'm like, of course,
you've got this perception,
this perception network, all
your senses, and everything.
You've got this brain.
Of course, I would be surprised
if there were not stories like this,
as people approach death.
As the system is shutting down,
of course, you're gonna
see some weird stuff.
But if I could tell you that...
Like if I had one of these experiences
and I was telling it to you,
or I'm just fascinated by it.
It would carry some weight.
It is a Netflix show.
It's just a show.
I don't know these people.
It's obviously produced.
It's obviously curated in a
way from a certain disposition.
The whole point of the
people behind this thing
is to get you to believe it.
You gotta know that there's
some propaganda involved.
And so you gotta know when
you're being subjected to that,
but don't you just want to know?
Aren't you just fascinated by it?
I get that.
The what happens afterward,
but like when she's talking
about the nightmarish parts
of like being conscious
but being unable to move,
I'm not trying to go back
to the surgery part of it,
but yeah, it's just like thinking
of the ways that you die.
I'm fascinated by the
afterlife part of it.
But the actual death-
Especially the getting
there is the problem.
Yeah.
But it's about the journey, man.
It's not the destination.
It's the journey.
I mean, am I gonna
appear to myself smiling,
well, along with you?
Well, no, it'll probably just be me.
Okay.
It must be me sitting next to you.
I'll be in your periphery.
You'll have to turn to see me.
Right.
You'll be on my right as usual.
Your seat at the desk.
This is fun.
I mean, the thing that I do like,
I like hearing people tell their stories.
It makes it believable.
I mean, of course, I don't believe
anything anybody said today,
but I almost do.
It's all made up.
Listening to their voice.
1-888.
EARPODD1.
I have a wreck.
Wreck it up.
It is a TikTok account.
Oh, I'm always looking for more TikToks.
Well, I recently shared one of the TikToks
from this particular
account with a group thread
that we're on.
Oh, you're talking about the guy.
Talking about.
With beard
@VCR_PARTY.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I found my love language and
it is watching old footage.
It's turns out that this
is the, okay, I mean-
Not a lot of followers.
I mean, it's not even a verified account,
but it says official TikTok
of Found Footage Festival.
Yeah, yeah.
Found Footage Festival
been going for many years.
I knew about that.
So I mean, guess it is the official,
well, y'all need to get verified.
Come on now.
So I don't know how the
rights to this stuff work,
but I mean, the thing that is
the most entertaining to me
thus far, and I haven't dug deep.
And the thing that I sent the
group is that dude's like,
there's these dating profiles
where people from the eighties
would go on and they would
like talk about themselves.
And apparently, it would
go out on a videotape
for women in the area to watch
and figure out if they
would wanna date these guys.
And there's just this one
guy and he is the best.
It's like, they don't make
people like that anymore.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
I was like, looking, not just his hair
and the way he was dressed,
but like the way he talked
and the way he moved his face and stuff.
Yeah.
He had a Mariannette quality to him.
Just go to the account
and just start watching.
You're either gonna love it or hate it.
You know what I'm saying?
Either this is what you
like, or this is like,
why does anyone like this?
It's a lot better than reading
about all the other stuff
Rhett's been reading about.
Find out what kind of person you are,
@VCR_PARTY on TikTok.
Love it.
All right.
#Earbiscuits.
I think I just choked for a second.
A little hot sauce packet.
I choked on my thoughts.
For me, the lyrics to
the song, "Sledgehammer"
went totally over my head.
I watched that video a million times
'cause it was like a fun music video.
And I was a little kid, I don't know,
six years old, seven years
old when it came out,
I watched it constantly,
but open up your fruit cage and let me in,
wow, I had no idea.
Hi my name's Rachel.
I'm a big fan.
So song lyrics that went
over my head as a kid,
my parents were musicians.
So we always had music
playing in the house.
And I remember a couple of specific songs.
The song "Hair of the Dog"
by Nazareth features a lyric,
now you're messin' with a son of a, blank.
And when I was apparently a
small child and my sister too,
my sister and I would
run around singing it
in our squeaky little voices.
And dad loved to tell that story.
Another time, we were listening to, gosh,
I forget the name of the song,
but it's by Steely Dan and the lyric is,
the Cuervo Gold, the fine
Colombian, makes tonight...
I can't remember,
but I asked my dad what Colombian meant
and it was a reference to drugs,
but he told me, "It's coffee, baby".
And he loved to tell that story too.
Anyway, I'm a big fan of you guys.
Thank you so much for doing what you do.
Bye.
Hey, Rhett, and Link.
My girlfriend, sulcata
desert tortoise, and I
are tanning out in the grass
and we just wanted to say 1-888-EARPOD1.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.